hello everybody it's yours truly ethan
klein of the h3 podcast today's episode
it's sponsored by yours truly at Teddy
fresh we got a lot of fascinating things
to get to II love courses with me say
what up my damnation mom nation my mom
named Scooter named Scooter nation but
so first of all I need to talk about
this pop eyes first chick-fil-a battle
now I'm doing this at the top of the
show because I don't wanna get food
poisoning and these sandwiches been
sitting out already for two and a half
hours when we did the Arby's challenge I
had diarrhea for three days and I'm not
I'm not saying that like oh I had Arby's
that I had diarrhea I had diarrhea for
three days
I don't know if that was the Arby's or
the fact that was sitting out for like
three hours before I got to it I think
it should be able to last three hours
though yeah I think the food regulation
in a restaurants for right can only be
sitting out for four so we were in the
window for I don't think so but
everything I've read is like you can't
even leave chicken out for an hour well
check it well does it check what about
what about steamed roast beef so Popeyes
has come out with the chicken sandwich
now Popeyes is a chicken place
people have long held chick-fil-a to be
the gold standard of chicken sandwiches
I don't know what took Popeyes so long
to figure out that they should make a
chicken sandwich but hey here they are
2019 making a chicken sandwich and
people are losing their mind
for example ian was at Popeyes at 10:30
in the morning not a breakfast item Ian
tell me about your experience at Popeyes
this morning at 10:30 it was like packed
line was basically out the door 10:00
a.m. and like a minute wait are you
doing a sandwich right now I was I had
to try it which one did you talk about
it
which one the Popeyes yeah yeah alright
well save your thoughts your you you're
gonna participate right you've got a
chick-fil-a back there - yeah okay good
but go ahead sorry I just you were
eating and I had to it was like a
30-minute wait at 10:00 a.m. for a
chicken sandwich so dude I crazy it's
not limited time it's just everyone's
going crazy over this popeyes chicken
sandwich I even saw quavo of uh of
what's his what's his band name Oh migas
amigos here you go
slinging them for $1000 at the back of
the car expect we have more I was
expecting when he open his trunk to have
like a thousand man I tell you these
guys I don't understand I mean they
speak at another
got 1,000 a chicken thousand that part
of the Glenridge now electric on the
broom
cuz I heard cardi B doing that is it Ian
is that mean chicken or is that just
kind of a it could mean a lot of
different things I think it's just the
chicken don't play for real cuz that's
what chickens say because I've heard
cardi B using that expression and
various situation really good versus I
did good didn't I you love yeah yeah
glad you'll you try I can't do that try
but I think it's an english-speaking
thing that oh really
cuz it's like the are maybe I'm wrong
maybe I don't know the I think I just
suck anyway we don't need to go to quavo
for a thousand we got Ian in line at
10:30 Bay okay so chick-fil-a is that
you can play some Popeyes was a lot
burger no Popeye's Chicken so they never
made the chicken sandwich even though
they've been around for decades they
never thought they'd never thought of it
but [ __ ] so chick-fil-a is these
Christian owned I think it's like the in
and out of chicken and I have to I got
to eat some crow a little bit here
because when we did our fast-food rating
I put your flat low because we never
really tried it I got it I cut a lot of
[ __ ] yeah and I have to tell you guys
I've since gone to chick-fil-a yeah and
I have to place them up I would place
them up at AAA after after eating there
because the service the quality I mean
the the whole experience of going there
and I'll tell you I do I uh III misspoke
okay I caution I got a lot of [ __ ] and I
agreed that I should have given more
respect to chick-fil-a apologies to
everyone all these people who are
unsubscribed get the word out know that
I've corrected the record so no what
about Popeyes
have you ever I've had Popeyes a long
time ago
but it's it's like it's a chicken place
I mean what do they sell you guys just
like chicken on the bone like KFC style
yeah exactly
they're purists I guess and they said
the sandwich is below
the quality of chicken that we serve
here at Popeyes interesting as the name
indicates it's a classy joint the
Twitter accounts started beefy even so
chick-fil-a took a dig at Popeyes they
said bun chicken pickles where the
original all the love for the original
Wow
so they're the original they're saying
well it's a chicken sandwich I mean guys
it's not that revolutionary I don't know
if you can claim credit for bread and
chicken and pickles
but Popeye says y'all good and I that's
a little too Street for me decipher what
that means but I think what they're
saying is like why you trippin okay is
that correct
it's like essentially just yeah cuz I've
got a lot of likes and retweets so
certainly there's a lot of meaning
packed into the they say like you guys
got a problem yes yeah right right
you got a problem and then in the
comments is for all-out war drag their
Trump supporting asses oh wow it's the
the sandwich wars become political come
on I mean Popeyes right now here you go
you know this is right now
no you know you're not baby and it's
okay you're not good it's okay it's okay
to not be good there you go
there was one I wanted to show you guys
oh wow that's a really awful edit
there was one reaction gif that shocked
the hell out of me that was like so
vulgar I want to find it here this one I
was like what is rogue these girls dude
this is they go Popeyes gang we ride out
at midnight is what they said and listen
to what these girls say cuz it scares me
I felt that very they're spitting
they're grabbing the hair they're
beating I mean I don't know I didn't
it's good that's cool he was down she
likes that call-and-response she's but I
like it too we look Wendy's tried to
jump in but Wendy's I mean seriously
just [ __ ] stay in your lane dude
she's go away Wendy's please y'all out
here fighting about which of these fools
as the second best sandwich you know
what's the real truth it's the same
social media guy managing all three
accounts I've long said that it's I hate
it I hate most of all I hate the one Ds
guy just shut up good does the brands
are so annoying
yeah stop saying y'all I mean it's
really just hello fellow children would
you like to try my KFC people are
falling for it though people love this
[ __ ] they love but it's literally just
some dude in a suit trying to pretend to
be hip to sell you a chicken sandwich
hello in a suit I think it's a kid no
it's a kid but you understand the man
USA Today ran a scientific poll a very
scientific poll on Twitter
chick-fil-a actually edged out which is
surprising because I mostly see your
eyes is better which is yeah I mean so
you're saying people think Popeyes is
better that's what I'm seeing yeah most
people are seem to be saying that
Popeyes is better now there's even
conspiracies around that poll people are
saying it's being brigaded by christian
groups because they support chick-fil-a
it's all very political review brah even
dead are anticipated this legend on
empty food you know that helpful I mean
I'm still a fan of chick-fil-a I gotta
say both of these are equally I mean
they're both they're both good okay I
have to tell you this what he says
chick-fil-a edges out right uh yeah you
seen yeah he gave the slight edge to
chick-fil-a but it's very scientific
about it though yes as he I love how he
just fired I'm gonna do secret if I only
eats it there's the pickle you know it's
time you tomato
the one thing compared to the
chick-fil-a sandwich that's a huge way
this is my favorite part of this review
let's see which one is better here we go
this is my favorite part turn it up turn
it up
sit back you turning it up I ever
cranked yeah good you know is that how
arias Amara started from review brah
yeah she loved it
he's not afraid to take the time to
focus in and give a fair evaluation so
there you have it
he gave a slight edge to chick-fil-a and
then so I mean his opinion holds a lot
of weight in this world of feud reviews
but frankly I don't think anyone can can
end this debate like me I'm a fat guy
I eat way too much fast food I'm a fat
mother I think I love chicken sandwiches
I love all food in fact and I'm ready to
do this test and ela on the other hand
is very picky and she did man's quality
she demands attention to detail so I
think this is gonna be a really good
test
now is there what's the what are we
testing against so here's one sandwich
from Popeyes now right off the bat I
like the packaging of chick-fil-a I
agree I don't like the bag yeah
reminds me of getting food from like
7-eleven hold on now what did you're
dissing the bag but the bag has a foil
lining I noticed which kept it much
hotter okay over time all right
the flimsy little usually usually don't
wait three hours to eat mine that's true
so this this is just the classic I just
see pickles and mayo
this is Popeyes okay here we go
what a great show I could get a bite
pickle you know I don't belong for a
second bar I mean no surprise mm-hmm no
surprise you what am i seem that
impressed it's pretty much exactly what
you'd expect are you going for a third
we're just tasting you no no we got a
show to run that's a taste for me I'm
serious
the guy who's doing these [ __ ] just eat
fast food from you
I think the bread is nice the pickles is
nice there's a nice harmony there's a
nice balanced simplicity mm-hmm it's a
good sandwich the bread is super chewy
and nice and I like that it's not oily
on the outside now that is not a bite
because it tastes of the pickles chicken
the bread no but I'm trying to not eat
in front of a thousand people a million
piercings like all right well what do
you think it's a good no I think if
we're going over to this this is the
apples apples okay this one's smaller
I'll tell you right off the bat oh
there's no condiments on it is that
meant to be that's just the plain
chicken sandwiches Wow no condiments
okay just pickles under it or thing
I mean I honestly would say they're
identical they're literally identical I
like that there's condiments on that one
though I feel like the flavor is what I
need to taste it's the same thing I feel
like it was good actually the bread is
non-drying how you gotta taste that one
we're doing a taste test I tasted it all
right
you didn't taste the chick-fil-a one no
I know what do you mean there's two
different sandwiches
this is Popeyes this is chick-fil-a no
yes oh it is yeah when did you grab I
thought everything in the bag in the bag
okay guys I'm not just eating for a
hobby really I know you think I am cuz I
thought chick-fil-a was in a box that
one is that's the deluxe that will could
be getting to next okay okay so go ahead
this is a chick-fil-a alright goodbye
right down the middle
Paul Pius is bear wow you are instant I
want to break it down better flavor Wow
holy [ __ ] I mean I'm so on the fence but
I'll say I'm Popeyes credit it's bigger
he's put together I think there's more
going on there I like the condiment I
think I could give it to pop I still I
think that chicken tastes better
chick-fil-a it's got like a weird flavor
I don't like how this I don't like it's
like look chicken and bread and pickles
it's a little too simple for me let's
move it on to the deluxe I feel like
this is the real test is the chick-fil-a
spicy Deluxe now this is more my speed
here you got a spicy chicken and we have
this from Popeyes yes okay you got the
lettuce of tomato the cheese that looks
like a commercial I have to say that
yeah perfectly constructed from chick
for a look at that it's picturesque yeah
Arby's take note that looks amazing
[Laughter]
that is a bite out of the commercial by
that one for sure hmm okay give that
give that here do they here girl
yeah we can't do this segments I'm sorry
mmm I'm not down how is anyone watching
this yes yeah you guys gotta help me
Arby's uh yes I'm trying
Ethan what am I supposed to I'm getting
lost in the sauce sandwich I get that
sandwich of five a five out of ten
it's good okay Popeyes hi this gonna be
hard to top this is the last of this
kind of segments we do or bees whatever
I'm really just printer foot down man
all right you lose the boss now okay so
this is their premium it's just got some
like spicy mayo and by the way Popeyes
that's a pit cold coverage is weak as
[ __ ] and doesn't look good yeah
chick-fil-a presentation ten it's sad I
mean it's a pig it's like a commercial
yeah all right God you want to see how
to take a bite
okay every once in my life yes hmm
the Julie did not elicit that kind of
reaction from that was better that is
viscera and I say immediately Popeyes is
about I never expected that sandwich is
so bomb no chick-fil-a it looks okay but
come on wear it to eat oh it's like oh
and it's legit spicy too the chick-fil-a
spice is like oh no you look in here I
knew that I never had anything that
delicious any one more bite okay this is
my life
I passed the Sam this is my line of the
podcast anymore that sandwich
I'm not slaying girl yeah chick-fil-a
doesn't make me okay that crazy no way
am I crazy
am I crazy or is this crazy no this is
yeah I'm with you
thank you got your back no next time
next time when I ask how is the diet
going maybe you guys won't be so upset
at me because I saw people saying like
not cool with that comment really I
thought people thought it was funny I
thought was nothing oh my god okay
Popeye's so blows it away holy crap by
far I have to say the presentation on
that spicy deluxe I was like come on
House Popeyes gonna beat this that
Popeyes sandwich wouldn't hit your mouth
it's got the spice it's not the pickle
let me go in for another bite no no I'm
kidding
chick-fil-a flavor is so weird I never
liked it I'll tell you what this the
texture of the chicken has a little
strange thing and the chick-fil-a to it
it's weird
Wow Popeyes there you have it folks
that's it there's nothing else to say
and if you want my I didn't like one of
the best I've tasted
if you want my recommendation that spicy
chicken sandwich from Popeyes it's crazy
dude ah hold on let me pull this up to
it I'm with these girls right now
let me join there yo yo chick-fil-a I
got a message for you i'ma stop on her
face and when I I'm gonna fit in her
mouth I'm a poop in her face I need this
to wake up every morning I want Popeye
gang yeah oh how long we know we break
or we're keep going let's see we got
about six more minutes break down whoa
that was intense I tell you that spicy
didn't it shocked the hell out of me you
know I gotta say you know I've been a
vegetarian for a long time so I don't
really have a horse in this race however
back in the day when I was between like
KFC and Popeyes Popeyes has always been
waiver so I never had Paul bite its head
up once or twice a time in do you have
any thoughts on this cuz you're
participating as well I think
chick-fil-a is the most overrated
fast-food place ever
oh [ __ ] this is excuse me it's America
we fooled by what we drove all the way
to chick-fil-a in Agoura Hills from the
valley and it's [ __ ] closed on Sunday
I was like [ __ ] if you got to be a
church gets fire some juice they'll work
on Sunday or something you get that [ __ ]
in Israel why did I move here right and
Israel everything's closed on the
weekends I'm American well you know this
is it's like the flood gate is open to
criticize chick-fil-a all of a sudden
now all the haters come out of the
woodwork I don't like their fries you
that you would think that you wouldn't
be able to mess up Chris cut fries what
they suck the chick-fil-a sauce though
is
it's a 1 it's the best mayonnaise
there's a do we have any day and I grab
some horsey sauce it's like well anyway
Popeyes congratulations we wish you well
I'm gonna go burn down a chick Blaine
stomp that hoe meanwhile there is
something else that I think would beat
all of them recently stumbled across
this home cooking video it's probably
for royalty free but what you have here
is a deep-fried be be cute chicken
pepperoni deep-dish quesadillas sandwich
it has 20 million views and you'll see
why when I was watching this house like
oh it's just like you describe what it
is it's just so it's ground chicken with
barbecue and now they're adding some
onion and cilantro and green onion and I
was like yeah it's like a barbecue
chicken quesadilla I don't understand
what's the big deal push down some
tortilla what do you call that baking
it's like one of the flute the baking
flute or something she's laying down a
ton of chicken a lot of bark very saucy
yeah I want to say too little too saucy
Tong Marchese another quesadilla I'm
pressing it down what just the door to
you
quesadilla oh yeah just said yeah we've
got a little sauce here why not it's one
of these videos that just keeps going
yeah some del powder that part I don't
really get the del powder know that
already looks like an abomination it's
like a case it barbeque chicken
quesadilla that's like an inch thick
inch and a half thick so now she takes a
fat slice and pan basically batters it
with powder an egg and breads it why I'm
assuming she's gonna deep-fry it yeah
now we're deep frying the like in
in a half chicken quesadilla into now
what looks like a pie by now you've got
the whole quesadilla deep-fried on a
pizza dish and she's putting marinara
sauce a lot cheese and pepperonis and
baked it again so here you go
this monstrosity the the beep deep-fried
Biba cube chicken pepperoni deep-dish
quesadilla sandwich oh my god I think
that's gotta be well a for effort
certainly I'm sure it tastes like ass
though because you have like so much
barbecue sauce in there remember just
nasty one slice is that is like ten
thousand Colorado yeah but I mean props
they did it good so there you have it
right I guess you always got to push the
push it further I wonder where they
could have probably taken it further you
know to be great once it's a pizza blend
it up and turn into a smooth that
something says and Wendy oh yeah just
undo it all what you do is after you do
all that work you blend it up add
breadcrumbs and then turn it into like a
meatball or something just start all
over all right well let's take a quick
break I need to lay down after all that
how long do I eat a lot of chicken right
now I had to do it for the game I had to
give up that I had to give Lila you saw
the excitement you saw how weapons on
the line can evaluate on a little
chicken bite okay a little nibble maybe
here I'm here to entertain I'm just glad
it was all on video and everyone can see
what I see
was it that crazy go ahead you guys
could tell me you got you got a twinkle
in your eye for sure well yeah there's a
flash they reminded me of when Bilbo
wants the ring well more yes thank you
before we go to break we we haven't just
discussed this but you tweeted something
this weekend
well I it's on my dock oh you were gonna
bring it up yeah of course talk about my
nudes of course but I'll give the whole
backstory to that so we'll be right back
I'm gonna take a quick nap we're gonna
come back talk about PewDiePie hitting a
hundred million and we're eating me to
edit it's gonna be so much fun we got
all my nudes have been leaked I'm gonna
talk about that I mean guys this whole
episode of your life it's not just easy
okay we got we got real contest
all right today's episode is sponsored
by yours truly
okay Simpson no not OJ Simpson illa
Cline all right basically what I'm
saying is that we don't have any
sponsors today and I need to waste about
three or four minutes so that I can run
to the bathroom right now and heat let
me take this time to tell you about
Teddy fresh we've got a new collection
out check out this man yeah you're gonna
want this look at this patchwork hoodie
first of all one of the nicest items I
think we've ever made you got the Sun
Rise and of course the sunset now don't
even get me started on these elastic
fleece patchwork pants which are frankly
a technical master either tell me about
the construction of these it took us a
while to decide how to proportion the
all the squares because across the
different sizes it changes right right
it's like we go from extra small to 3x
own so we had to pick something that
would work for all the sizes so it took
a few tries and then on the side of the
short I like how there is a seam that
goes only on under the pocket and then
it stops so the panel can continue
without a seam so
like if you show a model picture of the
short from the side here you can see so
you see how the blue doesn't have a seam
it doesn't have a cut in the middle yeah
some some serious geometry going on here
yeah so that was all we got we got two
designers and we've all been working
hard round the clock around the clock
and it came out really nice and some
people I saw people wonder in what kind
of fabric wait this one is it's not as
heavy as the color-block no it's a it's
a lighter weight and I kind of think it
works better because of all the panels
mm-hmm
it would be to like the panel's come
where yeah yeah so but I think this is
just I love it it's so good it's so nice
so well made you can love this another
item we got here new ride or die baby
mock neck yeah I really like how these
came out and we got to work up with this
graphic more yeah we are we have the
etiquette that originally said ride or
die which I like a lot for the graphic
but we had to you got a brand it so and
then yeah it started getting messy
because you'll go right or die then you
want to put Teddy fresh somewhere so I
do want to work with the rider dye
concept with this graphic we do we will
have a long sleeve coming up that does
have it all this leaves yeah I want to
make like a jacquard sweater with
ride-or-die on the front with like
flames and [ __ ] you know sick [ __ ]
epic this shirt I'm wearing right now
dude this shirt is so sick let me get a
here so this is a heavy gauge the fabric
is unbelievable the embroidery is so
clean it's so nice the flame I mean this
R embroidery came out so clean dude
everything's just and then so you've got
the blue and the purple and you got the
pink and the white which I mean forget
about it you know what I'm saying pink
and white such a wonderful color combo
I'm just mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
love love love love love we did this we
did this last year in Paris which was
also really nice change some photos
these don't look very Peres see those
are just yeah these ones have Paris
there you go
there's life--all Tower mm-hmm some
other efforts yeah besides the Eiffel
Tower like how do we show us in Paris so
they go get their bike at yeah you go to
a cafe with a baguette yeah this one
yeah they're like look we're in Paris
forget about we got tons of new bags
besides those garments this is the
crossbody in two colors but bada-bing
and bada-boom all of them they're called
black backpack that was this is full I
made to everyone's demand people kept
asking why do we only make the meaning
backpack they wanted a full size so for
this fits a laptop yes Stan inch laptop
maybe you should write full size here
because they kind of it's kind of
confusing like you could almost click on
it you see I think full size color block
full size backpack would be maybe more
okay more expressive for people you know
because then any backpack which is ahead
especially with the ladies mm-hmm ladies
love that many cuz the size is so great
it really fits everything it's lighter
it's easy you can take the straps off
and carry out like a bag the fanny pack
forget about it I mean who you're
kidding huh and then also these hats
weren't or no - right mm-hmm
this really is very pretty okay there's
a lot coming up until the end of the
year there's a lot coming did we're up
to ten employees now at Eddie fresh we
are not kidding around we are working
around the clock this and you know what
work yeah we're slamming we're really
fun well it's fun to feel like you're
actually building a real business you
know like as they would say on Shark
Tank
are you a Juan Trippe renewer or an
entrepreneur and I think we may be
waiting in the territory
of not being a Juan Trippe renew or my
will see I love the one troponin yeah I
know it's the ultimate dis of Cuban
you're a water preneur should we say the
ribbon dip collab date sure and location
sure so September 20th there's gonna be
a mate angry and pop-up shop in New York
City and why see you the new rippin dip
collab collection is coming out we will
be there in person we're gonna do faces
with Prince Theodor that's a little a
there at the me he will not be at the
meeting but I'm already nervous about
packing like how do you pack for a baby
I don't know and it's gonna be fun to
happy in New York with them though cuz
like better you can't really bring no
which is sad and so it's but then
Theodore we're gonna be in Central Park
with little Bing bong it's me so nice to
push him through Central Park and fun so
we're bringing out my mom and my sister
yeah they're gonna watch babysitter
Patrol yeah and we're very excited yeah
so if you are in the New York area New
York City area you're not gonna want to
miss this epic epic pop-up it's a full
store concept we are coming out hard
when is it again September 20 it's a
Friday October 20 that's right that's
like a month away I know holy freaking
crap that you fast Dan how long have we
been going a long time seven minutes
what this isn't really an ad this is
just cast all right well I guess that's
enough that so we will be right back
from the bathroom and right back in to
the podcast welcome back everybody on
this beautiful Tuesday afternoon blessed
golden it'll never come again so seize
the day enjoy the time this is the
motivational
I was thinking about something
motivational to talk about yeah oh yeah
I remember what it was I was saying I
think about this from time to time and
it's a little it's a little anecdote
from my life that I wanted to share with
you guys in the hopes that maybe it will
hold some value to you now as you guys
know and I've said it time and time
again and I'm not saying this to
embarrass you or flattered you I'm just
saying as a matter of fact that meeting
ela has has been the cause of everything
good in my life
I mean besides having a loving
fulfilling partnership life partnership
it's also led me down the path of being
an entertainer which is something I can
almost certainly say I would never have
explored or achieved on my own as you
guys know the catalyst for that was that
you was in our class and she had to make
videos yadda-yadda-yadda
long story short now if you go back to
when I first met ela in Israel it was in
the myths of my most severe years of
anxiety disorder I was pretty much
dysfunctional when I think back to
myself I had so much anxiety and
dysfunction I mean how even holding a
conversation was was was extremely
challenging to me and I remember it was
so bad some days I would just stay in my
room sick because I told him I wasn't
feeling well because I just honestly
could not muster the strength to go out
and be with this group of strangers
frankly and I wasn't really clicking
with anyone because I was just a mess
anyway and so before I connected with
ela there was a young man on the group
who was a paranoid schizophrenic and
apparently he had probably lost his
medicine or forgot it or just stopped
taking it and he started going into a
very severe
episode of of mania and psychosis I was
during the first week of the birth right
where I wasn't part of it yet right
because um I was the soldier that they
bring onto the group and you guys were
there for two weeks and we came in on
the second week right so that either
wasn't there I didn't know her I didn't
matter but for some reason I was ended
up hitting it off with this I ended up
hitting it off with this guy a little
bit before before the episode kicked in
because he was kind of a loner and he
was having trouble socializing and I
think I just gravitated to him cuz I
[Music]
well probably a little bit because I
identified with him that I was kind of
suffering the same thing but also I
wanted to you know I felt bad for him
and so I gravitated to him a little bit
that was before the episode then once he
started losing his mind I get to other
something wrong with the guy because I
remember the exact moment he lost it we
were at some tomb and he we were the
whole group was there and it was kind of
confusing because it was this whole
mountain they called it like the unknown
soldiers tomb or something well there
wasn't really like a specific tomb was
more like a space and he raises his hand
and he goes uh is this the tomb and she
goes oh he says where is the tomb and
she says oh we're at the tomb now and
everyone laughs at him yeah I thought I
was like what kind of a valid question I
was confused about a tilt everyone
started laughing at him and giving him
[ __ ]
which is weird cuz they're all kind of
like in their 20s and I was walking with
them and one of these [ __ ] kids goes
by coast who I'll just call him uh I
don't want to use his real name I'll
just call him uh Michael Karl he goes
hey Karl
where's the tomb oh just like a total
like I said I mean it was so douchey I
was blown away and from that moment he
started acting super weird we got on the
bus
he was like totally out of it we got on
the bus I'm sitting next to him he turns
to me he goes the devil talks to me and
tells me to do bad things
that was what he's told me and I
immediately was like oh dude this guy's
like unhinged right now I don't know and
he's slowly deteriorating on the bus
he's like grabbing people in front of
him not like hostile or just weird
he's trying to talk to people and he's
hallucinating he's talking about he's
having like and I'm a little scared for
myself and the safety of others when he
told me the devil talks to him and tells
him to do bad things I was like like
what mm-hmm
like why don't you tell me like what but
then he says something like he says
something like innocent like oh if I
smoke a cigarette then I'll die or
something like that then he starts
talking about how he tell he starts
telling me yeah I'm schizophrenic I got
diagnosed but and I thought it was
better but you know he started telling
he was really dark dude he started
talking to me about like how he was
gonna you want he he wanted to kill
himself they didn't have the courage to
do it well I was like [ __ ] I felt so bad
for this dude apparently he was doing
pretty well back home on his meds and he
was working holding out a job but I
think just putting him in this it was a
very stressful atmosphere for him he
wasn't connecting with anyone people
were making fun of him for Christ's sake
so ridiculous so on the bus I tell the
guys is like hey something's going on
with with homie and we've got to check
him out and he's just he's out of it
he's totally glued
he's out of it like there's no question
about it like he starts struggling with
the tour guide and he doesn't want to
get off the bus and eventually we pulled
him over and the police come and they
handcuff him and we go to the police and
so I'm the only one that knows him and
they want they like are asking for
someone to help so I volunteered to go
help we go to like the police station
you
handcuffed why is he handcuffed because
he was just acting erratic you're
unpredictable okay I mean he thought oh
yeah right one of our tour guides he
thought was the devil and he punched him
in the face Wow
he goes you're the devil and he punched
him in the face he wasn't a small guy
either so he was acting like violent
actually at one point and well I'm gonna
tell this whole story because
interesting but I'm gonna come back and
and make a point of it so we're in the
police station
they're trying to a right they're trying
to get a hold of his family to arrange
home a ride home for him they don't know
how they're gonna put him on a plane
because he's having an episode they
really don't know what to do with the
guy and it was crazy on the way to the
PlayStation they pulled over for some
reason I don't remember why they pulled
over well he got out of the car and you
ran and jumped the fence into like an
orchid and disappeared
it was the craziest [ __ ] one of the
craziest things I've ever witnessed and
the tour guide and the police officer
are running they say stay out by the car
and they running into the orchid I can't
see anyone now on the side of the
freeway the orchard you know it was like
lemon trees and [ __ ] you can't see
anything and after like 20 minutes
nobody's coming he comes wandering out
by himself they're not with him and I'll
never forget there was a fence there and
he kept trying to jump over it but he
couldn't and then slightly to the right
there is a hole a giant hole that you
could easily walk through and he keeps
trying to get out and then he walks
right by the hole mm-hmm and he's trying
to jump over the fence right next to the
hole so eventually they show up they get
him they handcuff him to get back in the
car and I said to the tour guide I said
listen all I Bob I honestly I I
volunteer to fly back with them and cut
my my trip short
and well they they event eventually I
didn't have to do that they figured
something out but I was ready to leave I
was ready to go home and I mean the the
difference that would have made in my
life and is immeasurable I mean like
serious yeah that that I would never
have crossed that that crossed that
crossroad with you mm-hmm
and so he left and soon afterwards you
came on the group and I was in the midst
of dealing with all this I mean I was so
[ __ ] up I wasn't sleeping I could
barely function I was just a total
[ __ ] mess and this situation was just
even weirder on top of all that mm-hmm
and like somehow through all of that
like I was able to muster the strength
somehow to talk to you and I think it
was probably good in a way that you
couldn't speak English only because like
I was able to be more comfortable and
that yeah I was gonna say I couldn't
tell well yeah
most people probably couldn't tell that
I was dealing with that [ __ ] no idea but
anyway what pursuit what ensued was that
we hit it off obviously and the rest is
history but the point is that thinking
back on that is that like just pushing
through and forcing yourself to to do
things that are you don't want to do
whether you know you should do whether
that's talking to a girl you think's
pretty or staying on are working through
social anxiety or something outside your
comfort as something outside your
comfort like no matter what shitty
circumstance you're and you have to push
through it no matter what and and the
truth is that if you can't push
through that uncomfortable circumstance
that impossible circumstance it will pay
off every time mm-hmm
it will get better it will pay off you
got to face your fears and you've got to
just push through it looking back I
don't know how I did it for me it was
just like did he try to talk you into
non-living the guys they told me yeah
they did so like you just stay you know
you've helped enough like that's
ridiculous whatever but I was ready to
do it I just you know part of me wanted
to leave too frankly because I was like
so over it mm-hmm but when I saw you and
I and I kind of got over all that and
just tried connecting with you was uh
and even going on the trip to begin with
because I didn't want to do that just
the point is that if you can't get work
through all this stuff force yourself it
will it will pay off every time mm-hmm
and if I would have just succumbed to my
anxiety and the situation and the
circumstance that I was found myself in
and just been like you know I'm not in
the right mood I'm just this pathetic
anxious fat [ __ ] bearded loser and I
don't even try to talk to this girl or
orange you know come on this trip at all
my life would wouldn't would be
somewhere else far less good sure of
that so I hopefully think about that
that crossroad in my life because there
was so much going on and I'm very proud
of myself in retrospect for being able
to still connect make a connection with
you know somehow mm-hmm so that's just
my little story that maybe is useful
just coming out there I mean
I feel like I can see myself in those
situations a lot when I look back and I
always see that been the result of
pushing through down comfort like even
the idea of being in videos at first was
like just not even an option for me and
then look today and like I don't know I
still I still can't watch myself but
like I hate watching myself mm-hmm but
obviously I'm trying to work on that mmm
obviously it's insane Hey but I'm so
happy that we did that stuff and a lot
of times you pushed me to even
withdrawing and you pushed me through
doing more and not being shy and just
like I've on so many aspects wherever I
see that I I can I can point to myself
at a time when I did something that I
know I was uncomfortable doing and I
push through it I always I can see now
like how much it paid back always I
would even look to people out there and
and and to myself and you it's like when
you feel uncomfortable about doing
something sometimes that's your cue that
you should do that day there's something
that makes you uncomfortable then maybe
that's the thing you should be attacking
if it's something you want to do if it's
something you see yourself doing but
there's something holding you back you
know
yeah even with Eddie fresh like because
I got to work with people and sometimes
those meetings with other people seem so
impossible to me right and give me
anxiety just the idea of meeting with a
team right but then every time I do it
and I come back and it's like oh the
meeting was so great yeah so good so
productive yeah this podcast is an
example for almost like up until maybe
just now every episode was like oh like
I felt I got so anxious before and I was
so worried about everything and I will
come out feeling like [ __ ] but I knew it
was worth it and
and ultimately a good thing mm-hmm I'm
very happy that we we've be able to
build this podcast as well which was
something I was very uncomfortable with
from the beginning mm-hmm the thought of
being in front of a camera unfiltered
raw baby stuffing my face with chicken
getting drunk I've learned not to get
drunk and maybe not to stuff yourself
with chicken we're working on that I
ever stopped that but you guys know what
I'm saying yeah and you you you know
that's it
that's all I got to say and most of all
don't go on Twitter when you're on
ambien write down it's good advice thank
you
the ambien part well that just came out
I guess it was the chicken all the
chicken sandwich today it or something
but share that story yeah was that
Popeyes spicy sauce that me got me
feeling that I can't emotional believe
it like when I think about co-vice on
birthright it just feels like a
different lifetime well we're just a
bunch of stupid kids we're so young you
were 19 I was 21 you know I'm 34 you
guys I'm 31
so that was a long time ago yeah and you
are not very long in the tooth at 19 to
21 you know what I mean you're just kids
then yeah yeah I mean I see I see that
air of our relationship there's like
that era and then there's the yeah the
Santa Cruz era and then there's the
Israel area that's kind of it's all well
there's the Israel era there's a layer
but that's like the serious yeah it's
all part of the same story for me
Ezreal feels like a like a dream I mean
really I think if I really lived there
for five years and I it's just like a
dream to me like that it's all just a
haze
life is so weird it really is and we've
only been doing YouTube remember this
because this trips me out we've only
been doing this professionally for like
four five years five probably it's not
that long that's basically how long I
was in college
mm-hmm that feels like a haze I can't
remember a single [ __ ] thing from
college
yeah world of warcraft huh lots of World
of Warcraft
well that's it PewDiePie hit 100 million
do we have a ins Edit to first kind of
launch in this to this conversation I do
believe we do
where's can you play tours no my
computer no we got it we'll take it away
go ahead is my mic open yes okay so
young in put this together celebrate no
you didn't have enough time to complete
itself
he's fighting t-shirts t-shirts did beat
him we realized but he's overcoming
controversy that's him on the bridge
he's overcome tear series the
monetization minecraft is of course his
greatest ally Ian this looks so
ridiculously good
what was that Wall Street Journal Bob
that is the vibe though he overcame at
all and here we are YouTube rewind does
refuses to acknowledge him yet he
overcame at all very nice work there and
on that we're all very proud of you
mmm-hmm thank you
so he hit a hundred million I remember
him once told me that he was gonna
delete his channel when he hit 100
million oh yeah I don't see that
happening
no where's the delete PewDiePie give us
all the rest of us a chance how
unbelievable million million and what
what can you even say so ridiculous well
the guy the guy certainly earns it Yeah
right the hustle that man
he's clearly a good collaborator and
manager of people because he has a team
of editors that have worked with him for
a long time he's built a a workflow that
that is functional that allows him to
still live his life and making content
every day I mean the guy he's got a
guy's got a talent not just as an
entertainer but as a manager as a
businessman it's hard to find that
threat about people are so successful
it's always a combination of so many
things well I feel like a lot of times
people don't get credit for like I think
about for example someone like Kim
Kardashian mm I don't really know what
she does yeah but you know that she's
gotta be like a shark like yeah how do
you get so big here oh you're you're
right there is so much involved there's
so much more than just like having up
that body or that face yeah because
there's a million people that have got
the body or the face yeah I think you're
you're definitely right there's always
the what you see is just the tip of the
iceberg that's certainly the case with
with both Felix as well I'm sure of it
although I think people give him credit
but I think what you say is definitely
fair about people like him but something
I wanted to specifically talk about
other than just congratulating him and
is that all these articles I see them
all over the internet on my newsfeed on
Twitter on my home page everywhere or
all these articles from all these tech
companies congratulating announcing that
PewDiePie has hit a hundred million
subscribers yet they cannot help
themselves they all have the same exact
paragraph about how what a controversial
figure he is it's like they can't help
themselves it's like on one hand they
don't know what to do should they
celebrate him but they have to also
cover their ass so they don't get any
[ __ ] controversial youtuber everybody
becomes the words first so a creator to
hate 100 million subscribers
Eurogamer what a month to celebrate and
congratulations to PewDiePie then here
you go here's a here
the paragraph petaboys rise to fame
hasn't always been without controversy
Disney maker studio dropped him
following Nazi jokes and anti-semitic
slurs it really sounds so much worse
when they write it like that there's
like no context if you were just reading
that you also lay them at the moment you
know things are kind of like
questionable like it's not clear if it
is anti-semitic or not right that's the
controversy each time yeah but then now
when they report it it's like oh yeah it
was anti-semitic for sure oh yeah yeah
exactly well no I mean it just kind of
like because they're just they're just
trying to get a juicy story here and
they're not gonna spend the time to
explain any nuance you know what I mean
he made Nazi jokes and anti-semitic
slurs it's like okay he hates Jews then
another incident including a racial slur
prompted Firewatch developer to file a
DMCA takedown he's worse than a closeted
racist he's a propagator of despicable
garbage that does real damage to the
culture around this industry Wow
that's the quote you found all the
sudden they turn into a hip piece that's
what that's my point it's like they're
all celebrating they want those juicy
PewDiePie Clips that's all it is they
want to show up in my home feet and
everybody's clicking it but then when
you get in the article it's they can't
help themselves it's all like yes thank
you for clicking but now I'm here to
remind you about all the terrible things
he's done without Eddie nuanced at all
in 2018 Peter buy promised he'd delete
his channel if he had 50 million subs
any trolled the internet oh is that is
that are we charging him with that no
what is this what does that have to do
with anything
so that's that was a Eurogamer than the
verge Peter becomes the first individual
YouTube creator to hit 100 million
subscribers that's the literally the
same huh it's the same title and then
here's the let's see here
but his fame has been hampered by
controversies using racial language and
anti-semitic imagery
the subscriber milestone nearly nine
years after the publication of his first
video oh okay well they think they kept
it pretty they didn't quote anybody at
least yeah like the worst possible quote
ever and by the way that guy who filed a
DMCA on his videos is [ __ ] [ __ ]
as a legal girl weirdo but it's like
okay Thank You Virg the gamer
PewDiePie's hit 100,000 subscribers
we're all doomed what is that angle how
they mmm how are we doomed let's see
well he may have lost the mean field
battle with Indian music channel
t-series he still remains the first
individual youtuber to reach 100 million
mr. beast helped him despite his success
in the platform PewDiePie on YouTube
have their own rocky history following
past controversies YouTube canceled
beautifly's YouTube read show I removed
him from Google preferred advertising
after he paid men on Fiverr to hold up
an anti-semitic phrase as a joke
well--don't has a little joke yeah yeah
that's such an important piece those
other ones we're like Oh without context
to make it look way worse still YouTube
tweeted out a congratulatory message
there you go but I don't what did you
read this why we all doomed dan I don't
know why we're doomed because he had
under million
I like that click they thought we should
do that we should name it die
let's name this clip PewDiePie hits 100
million subscribers and we're all doing
business insider PewDiePie becomes the
first solo youtuber to reach 200 million
subscribers Wow I've read that the title
three times already
the phrase subscribed to PewDiePie
itself became controversial earlier this
year after a man who killed 51 people at
two mosques and Chris Church hice they
went there no one else went there yet
said it during a live stream of the
shooting PewDiePie asked fans to stop
using the phrase and said he felt
absolutely sick and nothing his name
used during the attack for he was also
found chalked across a world war ii
memorial flown on a banner across
Manhattan
posted The Wall Street Journal's website
and displayed on more than a hundred
thousand printers Turing hacking and
PewDiePie has also separately been
accused of racism in multiple scandals
in past years in 2017 PewDiePie lost a
partnership with Disney I mean it just
it ends up just turning into an article
about what about all the [ __ ] up yeah
they're like it's like congratulations
PewDiePie and then that's like the first
sentence and then the following five
paragraphs are about his anti-semitism
and controversy polygon PewDiePie
reaches 100 million subscribers now in
YouTube's good grace death to a 2015
YouTube dropped him from Google
preferred these actions were taken after
he held up a sign on Fiverr that read
death of all Jews he asked freelancers
the hold up signed death toll Jews and
to surprise the workers did exactly that
the controversy in combination with
instance like when he said the n-word on
streams seem to have push you to to give
his biggest personality a cold shoulder
there you have it that one was a little
more fair mm-hmm and then of course the
subscribe to PewDiePie was the mantra of
the mass shooter they say that's a
little over the top a mantra like it's
all he says that's he's like subscribe
to PewDiePie subscribe be beautiful I
know it says the subscribe to PD by
mantra was hijacked saying it was it
wasn't his mantra it was just was a
mantra okay come on don't don't talk
censor when they say was hijacked by
mass shooters wasn't it just wine oh
yeah why are they saying plural I mean
mass shooters ma hijacked that mantra I
think there maybe was a second it's
really what I look that up right now I
know right I I kind of vaguely remember
that but it could be wrong oh maybe it
was in the manifesto of one of them I
thought it was just the Christ Church
guy I think he's the only one that
actually said it mmm I think maybe
another guy that's got to be a little
scary for Felix like alright till ya
PewDiePie hundred million subscribers
and surprising YouTube pays in tribute
yada yada yada
he has controversies the Han weird fiber
and Taysom attic Gaga it's like he will
never escape this [ __ ]
The Guardian battery beautify passes
under million subscribers it's like this
same [ __ ] anti-semitic jokes Nazi
imagery embraced by far-right figures
now that's not how that is fault
he was embraced by far-right figures
including the Christ Church shooter
that's not a far-right figure that's all
[ __ ] fart into outer space figure he's
so right he's not right he's just gone
he's in outer space who urged viewers on
a live stream of New Zealand mass
shootings to subscribe to PewDiePie they
act like that was done in a vacuum one
of his videos repaired man hired by
YouTube held up signed death to all Jews
there you have it so the media
congratulate you the mainstream media
congratulate you Felix this is every
single article can yeah as an author are
you able to write like how can you
approach this in a way that's like are
you all belated to bring these things up
when every time we talk about PewDiePie
like what do you think I don't know I
feel like at this point just choose if
you want a report about him or not they
want the clicks that's why they're doing
if you're so yeah exactly like you got a
pic no but they wanted they want to you
know they want to muddy him up so for
them it's the opportunity to get clicks
and muddy him up hmm but you could just
say PewDiePie hit a hundred million
subscribers you know trying to think if
you cannot mention it
despite the rocky year did he face last
year I don't know rocky out
everyone knows yeah well congratulations
nonetheless yeah I think it was the
PewDiePie week married hundred million I
got control
I was at marriage photos and videos are
like a real a royal wedding happen oh
dude they got married under what could
only be described as the most beautiful
gazebo I hope that gazebo real yeah look
at this gazebo bro well I don't know if
they got married on there but this
picture holy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah that's
a nice I gotta ask that it Kazee Bogata
photoshopped them out so we can use it
on Twitter yeah on the beach no less
that's gonna be hard to me like keep it
looking nice it's all moist
yes cells it's short yeah no it's a
gazebo you know what I'm saying like its
next level yeah it's a next level bow
physique I'm trying to think of a funny
name for a but yeah that's that brick oh
great I just closed my document
everybody's gotta wait for them ten
minutes now I just don't even understand
I was a scoop I was over here go ahead
and talk you'll think the way anyway I
just wanted to say again congratulations
to Felix and Moritz yeah not just Felix
I feel like we only talked about him
congratulations to both of them that's
right mm keep going doing great you guys
ever met her yeah we did yeah
boy super nice so rude oh yeah she was
nice of course she's a sweet man super
nice when they were here I think they
were actually shooting the YouTube red
serious right I was in it yeah we were
in we were in it yeah no canceled
probably for the best
it was it was weird
I mean not it was fun doing it with
Felix but the whole thing was weird
because you have a ton of these actors
a'm beats you remember the premise of
the show right it was like a real-life
horror game escape but they're just
actors and you know nothing happens and
you're just running and trying to act
like they're real they want you to act
like they're real are you supposed to
act like you didn't know that they were
they're kind of supposed to go along
with it you know I couldn't do it like I
couldn't your to Mara yeah I couldn't I
think I ruined that I think I was really
challenging for them to work with who
knows maybe it was funny I don't know I
will never know we shall never know the
truth yeah it's crazy but the budget was
insane like I mean they probably spent a
couple Millian that episode alone and
they just buried it right I mean they
just totally give up on that [ __ ] very
snowy I dia yeah I think yeah but I was
I was talking about PewDiePie last week
or when he got married I was like you
know what [ __ ] this guy and now I got a
double down on that
even more you hit 100 million he got
married and like the same week [ __ ] this
guy dude he's handsome he's rich he's
the most popular youtuber in the world
everybody loves him except you know you
know the Guardian and Eurogamer and you
know the gamer mm-hmm Business Insider
polygon whatever on YouTube loads and
that's all that matters
that's all that exists so YouTube they
tweeted their friends again yeah I
thought that was really sweet
everyone's like oh they act like he
doesn't exist thing but to get a little
info Matt hmm
get excited wow they were together since
10,000 subs that's crazy
Thanks so she wasn't even like she
wasn't even like a fan pick up I mean he
only had 10,000 subs at the time so I
gotta catch that again okay you can play
now do Twitter is killing me anytime you
pause yeah yeah
if you just bounce out a full screen in
back they don't want you imagine if they
just included the bridge video and now
he's playing Minecraft again what
happened what is this world Sark oh I
know
is he still making Minecraft videos as
far as I've seen on his channel yeah let
me see
I mean is he still just full minecraft
minecraft no cuz he was like only
Minecraft videos for like a couple
months let's see yeah dude what the [ __ ]
you still just making wait no sorry
oh yeah well okay whatever
[ __ ] I gotta get out of this mmm
congratulations
well I have a bigger question when it
can we ever just talk about PewDiePie
without bringing this stuff up as in
like the media like when do we forgive
somebody when do we collectively move on
it's a good question in general with the
council culture right
like people can [ __ ] up and then you can
move on let me just does he have to kill
his cross actually not every [ __ ] has
the same weight you know like how bad is
and to be fair he like compared to
things people have done anything he did
wasn't really
it was more like a faux pas it was like
a social goof nah II didn't really
harmony whatever it's all under the
umbrella of entertainment and comedy yes
he did actually go and punch someone in
the face he did not know he didn't
attack any Jews and he didn't even like
masturbate in front of anyone like like
flex a little glass look at louis c.k he
jerked off in front of girls
so is he condemned forever
yeah points that even louis c.k is not
forever I don't think it should be
forever I wonder how long before it's
like OD oh man remember that louis c.k
got was jerking off in front of all
those girls and be like what I didn't
know that like the good old days in
Hollywood like Weinstein and Les Moonves
man you could just be raping girls for
like 30 like three decades and
everyone's like that's just less you
know these guys it's crazy and now you
can't even jerk off in front of someone
yeah times are different how long ago
was the Christchurch shooting is what I
wonder who feels like it was like a year
ago I don't think it was that long ago I
think it was no I don't think it was
March March 15th of this year so yeah
we're talking six months but again I
mean no and I'm not I'm not putting that
on him but as far as you know time for
the public to move on sure that's
probably not long enough yeah I feel
that Association it did feel I mean I'm
I'm you know I don't watch PewDiePie's
content all the time or anything but I
have noticed there there doesn't seem to
be any controversy since then I think
that was probably a wake-up call for him
to be a little bit more careful the last
controversy well it's funny because I
feel like he cleaned up a lot and then
the n-word thing happened on the
livestream mmm that was before the
shooting oh they should well the
shooting was out of his hand no I but
yeah I see what you're saying all right
the
the shooting certainly I affected him
I'm sure of it yeah
I guess you're right cosmically speaking
and not that much time has passed since
all that's happened right so you know if
he if he continues on this path that
he's on now just putting out minecraft
wholesome my content for another year
people probably move on the good thing
about for Felix is that he works for
himself someone like Lucy Kay like the
door was shut the rug was pulled the
lights were turned off the big you know
cartoon cane drag them off stage right
but I mean well gong show
I'm not gonna say I could say what's
fair or not but yeah I do think that
people should be able to of course
depending on what they did but I like
our Kelly should go to prison forever
well he was committing crimes yeah um
but it's actions versus words yeah yeah
I think it depends on what they've done
and I think I don't think people need to
be cancelled forever I'm grateful for
that
uh-huh the Chappelle had this great line
and his new stand-up he goes you haven't
seen it yet yeah I know he goes uh near
Netflix Chapelle yes it was so good he
goes uh I didn't know his aria yeah he's
like with all this canceled culture and
all this he's like I don't think I've
done anything wrong but we'll see we'll
see that's how I feel well nothing that
people don't already know about cuz he
talked about like Kevin Hart I did see
that part yeah
and it's so true the guy okay you made
you know bad comments that he regretted
you regretted he apologized he moved on
and he doesn't say that kind of stuff
anymore
so he learned from his mistake and he
got better you know mhm and now we can't
forgive him so how is anyone supposed to
like that's his point and she was like
he's like I'm gonna do an oppression
worker I'm gonna watch everything you do
for 20 years and if I'm find anything
you've ever done bad in your whole life
I'm gonna try
ruin your life I'm gonna follow you
everywhere he's like you guys know who
that was and then there's someone in the
crowds like Trump he's like it's you
it's all of you the audience the worst
[ __ ] audience ever yeah people love
hearing up people to retell other
funnier people's joke just going it's
good
I already saw a Vice article about how
you can skip this one because it just
proves that he's transphobic he doubles
down on transphobia and I was like God I
mean you watched it is that that's not
fair way to characterize it I'm assuming
not but wait
that is transphobic yeah I mean is it
based in anything I haven't seen it yet
so I'm just asking he well he he
acknowledges that trans people I don't
want to say transfer he gets a lot of
[ __ ] for his trans jokes and but he
doesn't like apologize for it I mean he
makes more trans jokes I don't I didn't
find him transphobic nor did I find any
of his other jokes transphobic but I've
been accused of being transphobic
because I made a joke about cutting my
dick off and renamed and taking on a
female name and I got skewered somehow
for that I didn't even know was a bit of
a stretch thank you thank you for that
mm-hmm
well in short PewDiePie blessings upon
you and all the best James Charles
posted nude now Dan this is what you
wanted to talk about hey I can't show
any these photos cuz it's way too hot
for television but James Charles he
posted while read it to Dan don't show
the monitor because I'm about to open
this link okay okay good you can show it
it didn't open it he said hi I got my
account back just in case I've ever
hacked again here's the only nude I've
ever taken can't threaten me with it now
get a life and so it's a picture of him
I'm just showing off his ass which I
have to be frank with you guys it looks
like he has a simp Lance because it is
way too intense
way too voluptuous and he is tiny like a
tiny little twink like skinny little
twink and it looks like he's a head ass
implants so but it's fat dude is a
badass dude everyone's like whoa
so James Charles was trending I was like
what's going on and then I see this and
I was like boy you know there's a fat
ass and it's got two hundred it's got a
lot of likes but everyone's kind of just
clowning on it cuz everyone's like this
is not what I wanted to see right now
but I think everyone kind of sensed that
he just really wanted to share this nude
of himself because what's-her-name did
it well it started with Bella Thorne
Bella Thorne
yeah it started with her and then we had
um Whitney Cummings yeah right right and
and in someone's becoming a thing known
so I think just both your nodes yeah I
think he felt left out so I was watching
this sounds like man I gotta [ __ ]
post my own nude [ __ ] this guy did you
show him what these assets really looked
like I was in the bathroom taking a post
Arby's diarrhea I think it was on Friday
evening I can't show it I wish I could
no I'm just
it's only on Twitter you got to have to
follow me on Twitter and hbhb
productions to see my moods and so I
copy pasta de got my count back just in
case I ever got hacked again here's the
only live every day I mean I'll get a
life and I squeeze my ass cheeks really
hard no bathroom like he went to poop or
something yeah and I was taking care of
theater and he sent me on like a text
message check out my Twitter as you
weren't consulted no
okay I opened it and I was like wait
like it took me a moment like this is
public oh he's just sending it to me and
I was like wait well I got it ended up
getting a hundred and eighty-seven
thousand likes so my ass is almost as
famous as Jim Charles that's true but I
want to say that I I had to squeeze him
together because it wasn't funny
otherwise I had to make it interest and
like eel Allah I can do this thing with
my ass cheeks I guess cuz I'm sorry that
are like thick I mean no if I squeeze
them together it gets like rock-hard bro
like you can't tell looking at it like
if you touch it effect would bounce a
quarter yeah if you touch that in the
picture it's like oh well yeah so you
know always laughs when I do that and I
make her touch my ass and it's like
would so I hid it for hit one for the
bullet for the you know the world and I
sent out there and everyone appreciated
it so I don't know what's all the hubbub
about 187 187 thousand likes how do you
feel that so many people saw that I
think it's hilarious I mean I'm not
showing I'm just showing my ass
I ain't butt-naked though how are you so
someone said okay with wouldn't anything
someone said it looks like two walnuts
kissing um I don't know I just I just do
it for the comedy you know I was like
this is funny because I was trying to
think of a good response to him
and I had one like me like shirtless but
I was like come on this isn't good and I
also thought like James Charles is
showing off his ass implants I mean it's
kind of corny I got a show I got to show
what a real man looks so I hit him with
the regula and I and I and you know I
thought it was funny right
it was definitely funny I'm not very
funny and then they put you on ice ice
cream cone yeah oh that one was
beautiful and the Hank Hill ass
okay wait I didn't see any of those what
really yeah oh that was my favorite [ __ ]
but then I had people photoshop my ass
on James Charles and actually Joey
salads delivered the best one
unsurprising twist where's the Hank Hill
one I didn't see any I mean if you just
just Google Hank Hills ass I mean I've
seen Hank Hills ass no way I'm thick
he's flat get the [ __ ] out of here damn
it's not about the thickness it's about
the shape yes the exactly yeah I've said
I have seen its Danka idea I've seen its
assets hilarious so there you have it
guys never mention anything to me about
it I mean what did you guys think when I
first came across that I personally I
was thinking about contacting HR but
then I realized we don't have it there
is no way yeah
I'm HR [ __ ] Ian and I have a
joke that we don't have HR we have an H
K were you shocked were you guys both
discover no we didn't discover it
together over the weekend right I was
with a group of people though I was
looking at my phone and start laughing
we're here and they're like what's up
share I was like Ian how I was seeing my
news I was out at breakfast with my
family was like oh there's my boss I
want to ask were you were you at least
partially maybe not inspired but given
the confidence to do this by by Bert
because Bert just the other week posted
a picture of his [ __ ] nut sack on
Twitter no I didn't think about it's
yours like tame and compete yeah well no
no I wasn't I just thought I was like do
it it's just my ass you can't see
anything else you can't even see the
front of my body I was and this smile on
my face is genuine cuz I was looking in
the mirror and I
I am so disgusting like I have back
folds back rolls my ass is like a
disaster were you having to set aside
the ego for the comedy that's the that's
the joy for sure
and it's very brave of you to do
positive and I know that asked looks
like a [ __ ] train wreck bro but
obviously my F doesn't look like that I
swear I am thicker than a snicker a
shame that people can't touch it because
that's the real [ __ ]
the real yeah it was fun I thought it
was a great time and then I tweeted
something in support of ela and
everyone's like like an hour yeah we
can't just pretend like the James
Charles picture that's unreal
I didn't like his we are I mean I didn't
it's not that I didn't like it but it
inspired me because his was absolutely
humorless he was just showing off his
ass no I think it's a simple I think
it's an implant situation yeah what were
you saying you though just that it's so
unreal like the shape of his body yeah I
mean I look I could be wrong and I don't
want to take away this guy's hard work
if you're doing crunches all day but I
mean I don't think I don't see it
although the thighs are very thick maybe
oh man it could be real I don't take
away the boys hard work but I don't
think so I feel like I could see his
butthole from his ass cheek we're just
crazy because it's like a profile shot
that's all a very exciting yeah
thrilling stuff here sir there you have
it
we're coming to the oh no weather we got
so I want to discuss this meme that was
popular on the subreddit um this one was
making its rounds three thousand likes
Ethan you should have stopped abusing
Ian before it's too late
I don't know what they're talking about
I really don't know do you feel that
we've been abusing you in know before I
guess they they assume you're gonna yes
yeah happening to you and it's what
you're going to do yeah well I I can't I
know what they're talking about who's
the general like we're always we treat
in so bad it's just as much respect as
anyone here well I think now is a good
time for we actually have a couple new
sound bites so no go ahead
if Dan can bust those out gotta have to
be so bad Oh weird I have to pee so bad
I'm squeezing my dick because that's a
piece of it
look Ian I got no problem with the pee
so bad it's I'm not the one that's
running from by the way jack is the one
that started it all but here today why
are you attacking me for you in I'm on
your side I told you I always tell Zach
eight you know go light on the ANP
soundbites I don't remember that you can
ride those sound bites I don't mind it I
don't have access they don't let me well
there's no allowed below your pay grade
people don't think we pay you too I
think more because we call you the
intern people think that your unpaid
shout-out to the fan who emailed me with
the specific episode and time stamps of
times Ethan said I got a piece that's
super legit that's hilarious
it was like an early episode to he was
watching like an early episode and so
when you were talking about how bad you
had to pee I think I was drinking or
something yeah it was with posts so yes
[Music]
Ian you are paid that is correct yes and
you have benefits that is also correct
okay by the way I can verify yeah thank
you and by the way people there
such thing as a paid internship I know
it's like a rarity here in America
because people like you to work for free
I think when you say intern people just
assumed he was always paid and he was
always treated with the most utmost
respect
ian is a celebrated member of this of
this cast this production team and we we
cherish him and we hold him in highest
regard possible and because he has a
small bladder doesn't mean does it I
don't understand how that has any effect
on anything what do you I just don't
know what they're talking about Dan can
you hit those sound bites real quick for
me we love you in everybody loves Ian I
mean come on what does it have to say I
mean Ian this is your time if you mean
I'm giving you the platform now if you
want to hear out anything or talk to me
or you have any complaints I mean
certainly I don't want it to be too late
quote I've got nothing right now
good empty bladder chillin C bladder
fulfilled heart you feel a chicken you
find your way to my chicken I feel
really bad right yeah that got me good
too but you're you're feel you feel
fulfilled in your work yes yes mm-hmm I
was a suspicious yes yes those years all
right while classic is back moving right
along
World of Warcraft World of Warcraft
World of Warcraft classic is back the
original is back and it's so nostalgic
and it's so cool people have been
begging Blizzard to do this forever you
guys don't know world Warcraft is the
biggest MMO ever made me like many other
people got totally hooked to it back in
the what was it mm early to die don't
know like new mm yeah Michigan 2004 I
mean I can I can credit World of
Warcraft solely for the responsibility
of me dropping out of college I used to
skip class and play all at the time I
flunked out and had to do a fifth-year
but it was so fun it was so fantastic
and for many of us gamers you cannot
match the nostalgia and the beauty of
that fresh server it's so exciting with
having everybody in there and you're all
starting from the ground zero you're
starting with zero and it's like and
it's just it's so the adventure the
spirit of not knowing what's gonna
happen and it's it's just so exciting
and it's so fun
now Blizzard has been putting this off
because they thought it was all waste of
time and oh would you be interested well
let me put it this way I remember even
John John Sean made a made a video on
his channel rant thing about Blizzard
because they had a fan-made server that
was uh what they call vanilla and and
blizzard shut it down for copyright
infringement and they're like okay if
you're gonna shut us down at least make
it for us so we can pay you we want to
pay you and they're like [ __ ] you I'm
Blizzard mm-hmm
we used to be good but now we're
[ __ ] and though now several years
later they're finally doing it well
immediately shot up to the top of twitch
with almost 700 thousand viewers I heard
it was up over a million I'm sure did
that was a that was like an hour to into
it a chick twitch and it was already way
so let's say it had over a million
followed people following or watching
streams for tonight for example had 120
now the game will be patched just as it
was when the first expansion came out
the game originally released in 2004
there you go when the most popular video
games of all times those millions of
players however many people dislike how
the game changed over time
so Blizzard created the classic so the
game still exists but it changed so now
they keep adding more content and it
changes the game fundamentally it wasn't
just that they added it they they remove
the original world now that was like the
big reason it was pointless because they
made it so easy to level up so you can
participate in death and game even
beyond that they one of the expansions
it was like a doomsday thing happens in
the world and every and the whole world
was changed so like mmm the game that
you played in college
literally did not exist anymore you can
play it you can like visit those old
locations they just wiped it all out
which is why everybody was like just let
us play when we used to be able to play
so I think it's half that half nacelle
part part that part out and then mostly
just the I think the it's just so
exciting and fun to start fresh like
from zero with everybody it's just
really excite you look really good in
that bucket
so do it if I had more time I'd I would
log on that [ __ ] and I would [ __ ]
play forever you would never see me
again but I know that I just can't do
not allowed Dan just to give you an
example of how many people are playing
this dan logged in after work on was it
Friday or was yesterday yesterday yeah
and here here was the queue to log in
now this this happened in the beginning
so everyone's joking about how it's a
real launch experience to get into the
world
it says the realm is full your position
is can queue is ten thousand five
hundred and eighty four estimated wait
two hundred and thirty seven minutes do
you have to actually leave the game open
yeah wait
yes people were saying they would go to
sleep wait yes it's both the servers are
full to capacity it's just totally the
people want to play this game so bad
that was like the average a lot of them
had it worse than that even yeah here's
some other ones I saw some really bad
ones oh here we go number of players in
queue you can see oh yeah look at that
the last one at the bottom 24,000 people
waiting main 24,000 and and the wait
time is a thousand minutes mm-hmm it's
like 16 hours or so a thousand minutes
and by the way you uh this is a
subscription-based game so everyone
that's signing up has to sign up for
like a 15 per month dollar subscription
so Blizzard is raking it
Wow so even if you have the game
installed and you've already bought the
game Vega laughs yeah another 15 you got
to pay a monthly charge like Netflix but
a game and that's worth it well because
the game is they're constantly adding
stuff and it's online I mean there's a
lot going on it requires a lot of I've
never heard of that
EverQuest was uh it's got a bygone era
thing though because nowadays everything
everything free of boxes and [ __ ]
they've found different ways to make I
think I would far prefer to play to pay
because you know you're getting a fair
and a complete game experience yeah free
games free games sake games of ruin
gaming I slowed up twitch it's still by
far number one so see how long how many
people watching a 500,000 a lot
fortnight has a hundred thousand by
comparison
so definitely so well and also they're
just watching people like grind bores
like there's nothing actually fun to
watch about Warcraft
that's the kicker is it's it is a 15
year old game and it and it shows yeah
maybe I'll finally have a computer that
can run it now oh I forgot to tell you
that I just left i Alta I actually went
and got dinner and came back while I was
waiting to log in when I finally got in
it was like okay cool let's check this
out I went into the graphics settings
and turned everything up to max in it
crashed yeah you can do it I was after
four hours and you had to get back in
queue yep that's it didn't take that
long the second time though that's so
yeah back in the day I had to like turn
down the the distance you could see in
the graphics cuz I was playing like on a
laptop dude it was bad and then when I
won first went to a friend's house that
had a decent computer and saw what it's
supposed to look like I was like holy
[ __ ] this game is amazing and you have a
good computer then I mean you could play
over the potato now yeah I'd say
anything to play it now okay it's so old
yeah I mean that's the thing and
nobody's gone back to actually play this
game for what it is
it's a fifteen-year-old game you know
it's pretty dated but it's solid it's
that yeah it's fine it's fine but it's
the nostalgia you know like I said we'll
see how long it lasts
yeah I think I think it will happily
obviously won't be as popular but it
will it will lie
the fun thing is that it's like a
progression server so when you fully
unlock all the content and the original
and clear all the bosses and end game
bosses then the net the expansion opens
up and it keeps it keeps progressing as
people get further into the game very
cool clever clever
I mean okie said they gotta be raking in
so much money it's crazy
then there was this great thing it's so
crowded on these servers I've got one
more thing I want to show you guys if I
may look at this my friends and I had to
kill a specific NPC for a quest there
are so many people doing the same quest
we had to take terms turns I never
expected to see this level of
organization in an MMO so people were
forming a line to get the question mark
look at this this is happening all over
isn't that amazing forming a line in a
virtual world you guys mm-hmm here's
another one
same [ __ ] okay look at this line Wow
isn't that awesome
that's this is the magic I remember of
EverQuest of like you're in a real
virtual world with real people dude so
does this line really um it's a real
line you're like they're really waiting
for something yes yeah they're they have
a quest to kill a specific mob monster
but there's so many people in the server
that's amazing that they they all
decided to form a line I mean you could
cut to the front and try to get it I
don't know what yeah that's a way to get
blacklisted for life yeah really cool
it's pretty fun it's it's cool I got
honestly love to play it with you huh
but I like dude that would be so fun to
make to look I'll be a tank you'll be
healer you want me to play yes
we'll play together you would love it
because it's so simple from the
beginning - I can try and but I did you
like I'm not compatible with this stuff
yeah it's just it's very time-consuming
super well but I think we might have a
lot of fun maybe there is a big element
of designing your character and choosing
what they look like which a lot of
people there are a lot of reading in the
game no I mean you can basically it's up
to you I don't reach [ __ ]
yeah I never reach it [ __ ] stupid
these people that read all the books and
all about the Laura Mike do it it's
stupid we will read a book I promise
it's way better written you know these
people act like they don't know that
books exist it's way better I think what
could be fun we can try what what do you
like to play well you might enjoy I
think you would like the this the easy
kind of smash mmm the smashing I like
smashing or you could be a row with the
backstabbing hmm you could be a hunter
with the bow I don't like bows you don't
like bows one of us needs to be healer I
could be like a druid Oh kind of
all-purpose the roof literally I don't
know the language like what's a druid
you'll get into the world baby
it's like magic it's like a nature the
priests of nature you turn into a cat or
a bear I think don't worry about that
it's very with the the warrior and the
rogue is very simple you smash yes stab
I like that yeah I thought you would
like simplicity yeah smash boom smash
and grab baby I have a feeling you'll
play for 10 minutes to be like who the
[ __ ] who plays this cuz you have to go
kill a bunch of cats and then you go to
a guy yeah cats like bored [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you go to them busy the liquor
yeah you killed ten boys here's a
gauntlet some gloves and you're like cig
there's a lot of boar killing I was
either reminded about that when I logged
in just like oh wow this is just a lot
of boars
mostly what you're doing there's people
everywhere and you could say hi to that
we can try
and wave you know you could say what a
show off your gloves should stream it
that I mean I could be more go get
[ __ ] high good note I mean nobody
should watch someone grinding board it
could be fun though I like to play a
game with you okay
I have the mandalorian but [ __ ] them we
can talk about it later
for space crime [ __ ] them fish food
let's hold this [ __ ] off to fret because
I'm dumb god yeah we're uh about an hour
fifty we should be playing World of
Warcraft there you go
wrap it up and go home I think you
should be honest I think you should be a
rogue is fun cuz he does a lot of damage
a lot of damage a mage is fun to could
hear you do magic but it's simple answer
you don't like magic you shoot fireballs
it's just cool magic show you just shoot
a cool magic down it's basically the
same as good but just shooting down the
magic but I'm just trying to tell you
it's not complicated it's just you're
like a new Nukem is called you just
blast them with fire but there's like
different magics and then you're gonna
learn all that but it's slowly it's
slowly you just want to stab
[ __ ] what are their melee
classes there's warrior the Brogue
there's paladin [ __ ] that nothing you
know what clients so should be torrent I
think both torrent right I don't even
know what that is that's my problem with
this game it's like a big bowl character
sick
I like the torrent area to Thunder Bluff
I think it was called
well that's it guys thank you for
watching we appreciate you being here if
you made it through gonna have to be so
bad if you if you made it through the
munching and the crunch and the Warcraft
thing I have to pee so bad it doesn't
even sound like me they like the thing
about what about in hand islands like
these sound it's indistinguishable yeah
like I don't know why those don't sound
like carnac yeah and sorry be like
that's it going to play the I have to be
so bad
[Music]
barely hear it over the 10 other clips
you got only two are we wrapping this up
right yes even write it thanks everybody
can see you on Friday
it's been real
[Applause]